بعد 7 دقائق من الرحلة على ارتفاع 16000 قدم،
شهدت هذه الطائرة ما
يُعرف تقنيًا باسم تخفيف الضغط السريع، حيث
يندفع الهواء عالي الضغط القابل للتنفس
بالداخل إلى الخارج، ويأتي الهواء الرقيق البارد بالخارج
يندفع داخل الجانب الأيسر من
جسم الطائرة حيث
حدث هذا الفشل هناك  باب
يمكن تركيبه في مصنع بوينج،
يعتمد ذلك على تكوين المقاعد،
هذه الطائرة على وجه الخصوص لم تكن
بها، بل هو عبارة عن قابس يمكنك رؤيته
على الجزء الخارجي من الطائرة، هذه
الطائرة على وجه الخصوص خرجت من
أرضية المصنع فقط 10  قبل أسابيع، أصبحت بوينغ
الآن تحت المجهر مرة أخرى
بعد سلسلة من المشكلات مع طائرة 737
ماكس، والخبر السار هنا أن 171 راكبًا على
متن الطائرة المكونة من ستة أفراد جميعهم بخير وقام الطاقم
بعمل استثنائي